I just want to make a brief comment to
get back to the discussion about the
health disparities in in the
african-american community because it
really is very important and the reason
I want to bring it up because I couldn't
help sitting there reflecting about
sometimes when you're in the middle of a
crises like we are now with the corona
virus it really does have ultimately
shine a very bright light on some of the
real weaknesses and foibles in our
society and as some of you know I the
greater proportion of my professional
career has been defined by hiv/aids and
if you go back then during that period
of time when there was extraordinary
stigma particularly against the gay
community and it was only when the world
realized how the gay community responded
to this outbreak with incredible courage
and dignity and strength and activism
that I think that really changed some of
the stigma against the gay community
very much so I see a similarity here
because health disparities have always
existed for the african-american
community but here again with the crisis
how it's shining a bright light on how
it's unacceptable that is because yet
again when you have a situation like the
corona virus they are suffering
disproportionately as dr. Burke said
correctly it's not that they're getting
infected more often is that when they do
get infected their underlying medical
conditions the diabetes the hypertension
the obesity the asthma those are the
kind of things that wind them up in the
ICU and ultimately give them a higher
death rate so when all this is over and
as we said it will end we will get over
coronavirus but there will still be
health disparities which we really do
need to address in the african-american
community Thanks